el riñón que le transplantaron a jessica
solórzano hace menos de dos años corre
peligro
la cuarentena por kobe 19 ha afectado
seriamente al despacho de medicamentos
de alto costo por parte del gobierno y
los pacientes no los están obteniendo a
tiempo esta situación que empezó con la
crisis económica de venezuela se ha
venido agravando con las sanciones de
eeuu al país básicamente una sentencia
de muerte para nosotros porque no
tenemos cómo comprar los medicamentos y
el seguro social no nos da es una
desesperación en un miedo constante de
que el día de cualquier día puede
rechazar el órgano porque no tienen los
medicamentos y estefanía lugo de nueve
años tras un trasplante de hígado hecho
con la donación de 70 mil dólares tiene
un poco más de suerte porque una
fundación le está dando los medicamentos
más importantes aún con esta ayuda es
difícil para su madre costear el resto
del tratamiento por la situación
económica
está costoso la alimentación es parte
del tratamiento de ella porque su
alimentación debe ser balanceada muy
sana muy rigurosa en ese sentido y bueno
con los ingresos que percibimos tenemos
que hacer maraña las decenas de personas
que acuden a diario las farmacias del
gobierno y se van con las manos vacías
ya comienzan a tener consecuencias
alexander hernández pacientes con
parkinson dijo que recibe reportes
mensuales de que están muriendo de 5 a 6
personas con esta condición médica por
no poder tomar sus medicinas
soy yo pongo a siete parques o yo tengo
que salir con la condición que es lo que
interrumpir tratamiento que aún estamos
muscular tan fuerte que te pueda un
pariente estirar un paro respiratorio y
espero que el mero paciente está
sufriendo hoy en día el mayor temor que
tienen los pacientes crónicos en
venezuela que visitan farmacias como
éstas es que no pueden seguir sorteando
las dificultades y que tengan que pagar
esos tratamientos lo cual causaría un
daño irreparable en su salud y los
llevaría incluso hasta la muerte termine
fernández tras 24 párrafos